hey everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where today
my light is broken which is unfortunate
so i'm trying to light this video using
my monitor so it doesn't look great but
it's fine my audio should be very crisp
that's what you guys really need
so about two weeks ago i got my hands on
an xbox series x might even be three
weeks ago now
and ask you guys for questions and the
embargo for my answers
to your questions has now lifted so i am
allowed to talk to you guys about my
experience with um the preview unit
of the xbox series x which means that
there was still things being updated
the ui was not necessarily complete some
games weren't backwards compatible yet
um basically a series of things that
should be noted will be different when
the console is actually in its final
retail version or built but i'm going to
answer all the questions you guys asked
that i'm now allowed to answer so
dark dragon knight said how hot is it
really running uh keep seeing a lot of
stuff about it being pretty hot even on
standby cena view videos where they
mentioned it so
i can only speak to my own experience
and people with different units could
obviously
have different experiences in my
experience with my particular xbox
series x
it is warm on startup and then not at
all
it cools down very quickly even when
running games that i would consider to
be
quite intense like your red dead
redemption 2 for example
um which i will later this week have
um videos showing you guys load times
for naturally
i do not have any way to actually test
the temperature myself so i can't tell
you exactly what it is
but i am not even a little bit concerned
about overheating personally hopefully
this isn't a red ring of death situation
where some people are really hot and
some people's aren't but mine
not a problem deltoid said would you be
able to speak in depth about the new
d-pad is it an improvement how would you
compare it to others such as sega saturn
d-pad
able to test it with any fighting games
so yes i have played with the new xbox
series x controller and the d-pad is
noticeably different but i will say
overall
the new controller doesn't feel
tremendously different i don't think
most people will feel a huge difference
unless you are physically holding
you know two versions like an xbox one
controller and the xbox series x
controller in your hand
and i still by choice for vast majority
of games that i have played on the xbox
series x have actually chosen to use my
elite series 2
instead of the xbox series x controller
of course those are forwards compatible
meaning that you can use any existing
controllers that you currently have
on the series x and i personally still
think that the
elite is the superior option but yes if
i want to get detailed with you i will
say the new d-pad the material feels
lighter
and obviously it has more flexibility
points so it feels like you also have
more control
i am impressed with the quality of the
new controller
and i do definitely think when you
actually compare it to an xbox one
controller
it does feel like a step up in terms of
quality but again most people probably
won't even notice and i do think that
anyone who's used to using the elite
will probably just want to keep using
the elite i will say i really like
the share button is now built in and i
think that that was overdue
um so it being built into just your
regular series x controller is a win
from me
um yes it did try out fighting games and
for that i would still recommend the
elite series 2
over this controller but um yeah i mean
it it's
just a lightweight version sort of of
what you get
with the elite um that obviously doesn't
have that customization option
obviously if you don't want to pay more
i still think this controller is solid
um i think the improvement is very
slight but i like it shazam asked how
quiet are the fans during intensive
gameplay
and how long roughly to job
i should mean jump between different
games in the ui um
the fans are very quiet definitely no
fan noise issues whatsoever jumping
between different games in the ui i
think i have two videos
where you guys should be able to see
that at this point um i did have like a
couple of things where a game was
updating so it looked like it crashed to
a black screen because it didn't tell me
at the time that it had an update
certain games were not yet backwards
compatible and there was no way for me
to tell in the menu i just had to
consult the list that microsoft gave me
so i was like well i assume forza
horizon 4 is backwards compatible then
downloaded it and then
on launch it said this is not currently
compatible um which is because in forza
horizon 4's case
they have an xbox series x optimized
version which will be the only version
rather than it being backwards
compatible so
that will come but you know minor
hiccups like that obviously slow the
process down when you don't know
something is
uh needs an update or you don't know
something can't be played after you've
downloaded it
things that i am confident are exclusive
to the preview build though for the
games that i did
time um i got into a game in i think
eight seconds from startup to play time
i think it was
it was six or eight seconds generally
everything
quick regime is about eight seconds and
then any other game that's from ui to
startup
varies depending on the game um but it
actually seems like majority of the time
the startup for all these games is
slowed down by
you getting those like startup screens
with everyone's different logos more so
than there being actual loading
it's very fast um and i don't know that
videos
on the internet even sell it that well
because you don't realize quite how fast
it is until you compare it to what
you're used to
you know having an xbox one and an xbox
series x next to each other then you're
like
oh wow it's a huge
upgrade also just games that i had some
performance issues with
um i didn't have performance issues with
like literally no performance issues
with any game that i played at all on
the series x so
it's a speedy machine another question
here from gregor
how loud is it under a heavy load like
when watching movies and when it is idle
i have a small room with a quiet pc and
i hope the series x is also quiet yes
it's very quiet i didn't have any
problems with with noise or fans
whatsoever
i want to say it's like like my xbox one
x has also been very quiet but
this is just inaudible it's there isn't
even a slight
fan sound honestly um nothing that would
overweigh any game i played ever
so very happy with the sound of the
console it doesn't sound like it's a
rocket about to take off it sounds like
nothing
out of 10 how satisfying is the power on
sound the power on sound for the console
itself i think is exactly the same
the startup sound is different but you
don't necessarily hear it very often
because the console itself quick resumes
so it's kind of rare that you hear the
startup
sound actually i don't even know if i
could recite it
now that's a setting choice that i've
made too but uh
yeah i can't answer that i don't know
what it sounds like darbeins429 asks
where are you setting it up in your
space has its design complicated your
choice
um i have it in my tv display cabinet
where i have always had my xbox one x
that goes
under my large tv and i do have to have
it sideways i cannot
stand it upright in my display cabinet
um my speakers can stand upright just
fine but the xbox series x
is too tall uh i imagine i'm probably
also going to have my ps5
have to be horizontal rather than
vertical because these are big boys but
no it wasn't complicated at all
very easy uh setup the only thing worth
noting is that they recommend that you
use a hdmi 2.0
cable instead of a regular one so when i
was moving it to my pc for capture
purposes
i had the minor inconvenience of having
to take an hdmi cable with me
why normally i would just use the one
that i currently had plugged in but no
setup is not difficult and it looks very
sleek the box is
in person it's just very inoffensive
it's tidy
it's it's just a little black rectangle
that just
sits there and and um doesn't draw too
much attention to itself and i really
like that about it i think it's
large but it's subtle jack rumford said
the backwards compatible games have
higher frame rates even if they aren't
enhanced
yes they do anything that was unlocked
on
the xbox one x if you had an unlocked
frame rate um should be able to hit 60.
so of course if there's
a frame rate uh cap in the game you're
still not going to be able to do
anything about that that is set by the
dev team
who aren't going to change that kind of
thing um sometimes because it's done for
cinematic purposes they make frame rates
different
because of the experience they want you
to have that they think suits that game
for
any reason but yes if it was unlocked
you will hit
60 frames a second um again it didn't
check but i would say pretty reliably
another thing worth noting is um with
gears tactics or gs5 multiplayer is now
in 120 hertz
and that uh does feel impactful does
feel really noticeable
things are very smooth i also think the
uis is smoother and faster just across
the board doesn't look that dissimilar
to the xbox one x um
as you guys will have seen from the
footage here on my channel anyway but
playing
gears 5 multiplayer in 120 hertz
is noticeable the other games that i
feel like people are mostly talking
about um
yakuza like a dragon and dirt and
while yakuza does run um
4k in a way that is like it's very clean
it is a clean looking game
i think because of the style of yakuza
it doesn't do a great job of selling
the console graphically and i do think
that that is probably like sort of an
issue that the xbox series x has with
its launch lineup is that there is
nothing that is necessarily graphically
mind-blowing that really actually
properly shows us
what the console is capable of that the
xbox one x wasn't in a in a very
significant way those little upgrades
are noticeable and
are nice and are smooth i love quick
regime i
really really love it like it's it is
literally a game changer but right now
you know yakuza still looks like yakuza
and and thus stylistically uh isn't
something that is mind-blowing or
mind-blowingly next-gen where video game
hardware is concerned
but generally speaking i will say games
that i frequently play a lot
like this year i've on and off played
fable anniversary kind of repeatedly
which is obviously a backwards
compatible title did run way better
on the xbox series x just less frame
rate drops
or none at all because even uh fable
anniversary would have that in loading
screens on the xbox one x just the map
screen that stuff is just not a problem
on the series x and uh it is it is
really noticeable it's very
just everything about it feels very
clean to me billy zika asks this is a
good question
when sitting the console on its side
which side counts as up
uh how loud is the fan how strong does
it push air so we covered the fan
um there are little feet on the part of
the console that is supposed to be
uh placed down when it is horizontal so
it is actually very clear which way it's
supposed to sit
king auntie said how's the build quality
is it more plastically like the 360 or
does it feel a little bit more sturdy
and premium
definitely doesn't feel as plasticky as
the 360 and i think that that is um
in part due to the fact that it is a
very square design i mean there are
things that i love about the 360 like i
love that you were able to clip out your
hard drive and like take it with your
friends places which i guess now that
everything is on the cloud is no longer
necessary but i loved being able to do
that be like i'll just take my mirror's
edge save file to my friend's place on
this hard drive
i found that very fun but the fact that
it was modular meant
you know faceplates was cool for
customizing but it definitely felt a
little bit plasticky as a result like
you said i would say the xbox series x
feels premium in comparison to the xbox
360. yes
i mentioned this in a video before but
like the only complaint that i have
about the design other than its size it
is big and i would like to see a smaller
version that can still run in 4k which
obviously the xbox series s
currently can't and i as someone with a
4k tv have a preference for the x over
the s
as a result the only issue with the
literal
hardware external hardware is that it
will show your thumbprints or your
fingerprints
really badly it gets real smudgy out
there it will look
dirty if you've touched it too much
which naturally because i kept moving it
from place to place uh in order to like
a test things and be
record stuff uh because my recording
startup is different to my tv setup yeah
it ended up pretty smudgy you gotta wipe
it down
and that is my only issue um again other
than wishing it were a little bit
smaller but i'm a person who would same
applies to the ps5
way prefer quality and function uh over
you know it being a little bit too large
it's fine you can be big you play games
good
i appreciate you each ask where does the
heat come out from the system
uh is it well ventilated again yes i'm
happy with the ventilation mine didn't
get hot really at all
you know even after running games that i
would have thought to be intense um only
on startup was it warm for me
maybe my setup was just very good for
that i'm not sure uh the heat comes out
the top
so the the bit that you've seen it looks
green because the fan is right
underneath that so yes it comes out the
top
i did actually speak to someone on the
hardware team about
the top of the xbox series x um and the
holes that are in the top
seem like they're large enough to fit
things through and i am still concerned
about that where children are concerned
like coming along and just dropping
things inside of it i don't feel like it
would be hard to like spill a liquid in
there
and not realize you've done that because
it has like an open top on the console
and their answer to me was basically
along the lines of you know we've tested
this under multiple
circumstances we have checked you know
we've thought about people with families
we've made sure that if you
i am absolutely not being verbatim this
is this is just the paraphrasing but it
was along the lines of um
yeah we've we've designed the thing with
thought given to the fact that children
might want to interfere with these holes
because children are weird again
no microsoft spokesperson said this to
me directly but they showed me they'd
looked at it but that is the thing that
i am very curious to see how it goes
down the line because
yeah it's it's series of hulls gap fan
i just i feel like someone's gonna break
their xbox just by virtue of a child
interacting with holes
it's a concern kevin asks uh
they said they're wondering how fast
games load if you would have them stored
on an external hard drive compared to
the internal ssd
um so i i did do a small amount of
testing with an external hard drive
versus an ssd and reality is
if you didn't already know this the ssd
is always going to be faster
the external hard drive um i think the
the performance is still an improvement
over the xbox one x
it is still faster than the previous
generation but just
literally the reality of the way that
hardware functions is that the ssd
is significantly faster i know a couple
of people have done
um actual tests for this but i would say
the ssd
is faster by three quarters to 50
it is it is significantly faster but uh
it's not like it's a game changer to
have the console
running off of an external hard drive
compared to what you're used to with the
current generation you'll be fine
i think most of the questions i honestly
do have are all about the sound so yeah
this thing's really quiet
that's that's the biggest thing it is
really quiet
got a lot of questions about
refrigerators
oh my god this video quality is so bad
because i don't have a light
i'm so sorry everyone uh oh someone said
how heavy would you say it is
um i actually don't think it's very
heavy at all it's big
but it's very easy to carry it is very
light to carry so i had no problems
where that's concerned whatsoever
and i think that's pretty much it
everyone i will take any of the
questions here that i didn't have the
answers to
and uh get those answers and just keep
making content about it for sure over
the next
several weeks so if you have more
questions feel free to leave them below
i will basically make dedicated videos
for the things that people are asking to
see
is my plan just trying to inform as much
as i can alright
that's it for me today everyone i'm
sorry about the video quality
but it is what it is i'll see you guys
next time bye